as a an entrepreneur just starting out
i've been told that um
i need to that it would be good to raise
money
from friends and family most of those
people that are saying that
have friends and family who have been
able to give them um
you know sizeable amounts of money but
for those of us who
don't have that those means and uh those
contacts
what do i do sweat equity is the best
equity you start smaller
you know they're most businesses i'd say
at least 90 if not 95
or more percentage of small businesses
startups
can start without raising any capital at
all you just use sweat equity
now obviously we don't know what kind of
business she's trying to start
but you just have to try to start
smarter smaller
the hard part for most people is that
trade-off between do i keep my job or
how do i start a company when i have a
job
most people feel like they need to raise
money so they they can quit their jobs
so did you advocate they quit their job
no
no say go make it happen get some
revenue in prove it out loud i worked as
a bartender at night i mean
whatever you have to do that's part of
being an entrepreneur
so if you have to work on weekends you
have to uber at night uber on weekends
so you have some income coming in so you
can work on your your um
company or you work your regular job
during the week and at night
and weekends um that's when you work on
your start so the good news there is
anybody can be an entrepreneur if
they're willing to work their
ass off 24 hours that's what it takes i
mean that's your message
you know like they always say
entrepreneurs work 80 hours so they
don't have to work for you
you